[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the goblet of fire harry
potter and the tri-wizard tournament
more specifically we're going to be
discussing something that i'm sure has
crossed the minds of harry potter fans
at one point or another
what happens if you refuse
to participate in the fabled tri-wizard
the triwizard tournament is a contest
like no other an event dating back more
than 700 years that tests the
intelligence courage and strength of
those participating since its inception
the contest has gone forward every five
years with a brief 200-year pause due to
all three champions being injured in
1792 for pottermore the triwizard
tournament was first established some
700 years ago
as a friendly competition between the
three largest european schools of
wizardry hogwarts bobaton and durmstrang
a champion was selected to represent
each school and the three champions
competed in three magical tasks the
schools took it in turns to host the
tournament once every five years and it
was generally agreed to the most
excellent way of establishing ties
between young witches and wizards of
different nationalities until that is
the death toll mounted so high that the
tournament was discontinued three
schools three champions and three
challenges are the rationale for the
tournament's name with tri referencing
three and for years the tournament
stayed true to this figure of three
however in harry's year in typical harry
fashion he unintentionally broke this
mould and made it more of a quad wizard
tournament in the goblet of fire four
wizards were competing for eternal glory
one thousand galleons and of course the
famed and revered tri-wizard cup
breaking hundreds of years of tradition
harry inadvertently became an extra
participant being thrown into the mix
with victor crum cedric diggory and
fleur de la cour but my question is what
sort of ramifications did this carry the
whole tournament was created by parcel
wizards and witches of times past so i
can't help but wonder what kind of
powerful magic was in place to ensure
that the tournament remained on course
staying true to its original nature
given that each school was only allowed
one champion and that many students
wanted the honor of participating in the
tournament it only makes sense that the
fabled gopro fire would make the final
decision for who would represent their
school dumbledore explains the process
here
the champions will be chosen by an
impartial selector the gobbler to fire
anybody wishing to submit themselves as
champion must write their name and
school clearly upon a slip of parchment
and drop it into the goblet aspiring
champions have 24 hours in which to put
their names forward tomorrow night
halloween the goblet will return the
name to the three it has judged most
worthy to represent their schools the
goblet will be placed in the entrance
hall tonight where it will be freely
accessible to all those wishing to
compete one more thing worth mentioning
is that no student under 17 could
compete and anyone under that age was
quite literally unable to enter the draw
until harry that is just as shocked as
everyone else at the news harry being
chosen as a second champion sparked a
lot of outrage as many believed he had
unfairly circumvented the rules of the
goblet in order to enter after being
selected he summoned to a room to join
the other champions and it's here that
chaos breaks out school heads are mixed
of confused and furious and dumbledore
himself delivers the particularly iconic
line harry did you put your name into
the goblet of fire of course harry was
innocent but it was too late we later
find out that harry's entry was
falsified by none other than barty
crouch jr who tricked the goblet into
believing that four schools were
competing instead of three the worst
part of it all harry would have to
participate because you see each
selected champion was bound by a magical
contract to see the tournament through
to the end this is reinforced time and
time again first by dumbledore
once a champion has been selected by the
gobbler to fire he or she is obliged to
see the tournament through to the end
the placing of your name in the goblet
constitutes a binding magical contract
there can be no change of heart once
you've become champion and next by moody
aka bharti crouch jr he's got to compete
they've all got to compete binding
magical contract like dumbledore said
convenient eh
my question now is what if harry refused
what would have happened to him what
does this contract entail if we look at
harry potter cannon there are a few
other instances of magical contracts or
at least lasting magical enchantments
the most notable example that i can
think of is the unbreakable vow the
unbreakable vowel is a binding magical
contract that connects two parties the
purpose is simple it is to bind a fellow
witch or wizard to a promise after
stating each condition of the vow the
participant who is to uphold said
responsibilities must agree to them one
by one the unbreakable vow is a big deal
and what's the consequence of breaking
that contract why death of course there
are usually consequences for breach of a
contract and i can't think of why people
would be continually reminding harry of
his necessity to participate if there
weren't any parameters put in place that
in a way forced him to this leads me to
believe that there are two possible
systems in place here compulsion which
should cause the party to want to comply
with the contract in a way forcing them
to endure whatever it is they've agreed
to or enforcement punishment which would
effectively result in something negative
happening to those who refuse to comply
with the terms of said contract however
it doesn't appear that compulsion is the
system at play here as harry appears to
be very unwilling and reluctant to take
part only participating due to the
instruction of the tournament organizers
what this tells me is that enforcement
is likely the system at play which would
suggest that if harry were to refuse
something very bad could happen to him
this would also explain why everyone
encouraged him to participate regardless
of their feelings pertaining to his
entry
if you break an unbreakable vow you die
so i think that it's a reasonable
assumption to deduce that you also die
if you refuse to participate in the
tri-wizard tournament furthermore from
character dialogue i think we can
reasonably reinforce that this is in
fact the case
don't you said moody quietly it's very
simple karkarov someone put potter's
name in that goblet knowing he'd have to
compete if it came out
maybe someone's hoping potter is going
to die for it said moody with the merest
trace of a growl the tournament itself
is exceedingly dangerous and this is
also reinforced through the text so i'd
imagine that it would take some serious
enforcement to make it worth risking
potential death there must be some
lasting consequence whether mental or
physical at play provided there are
three challenges in the tournament i'm
of the impression that the punishment or
consequence may become incrementally
more dire as the tournament goes on
effectively what this would mean is that
for each challenge a participant refused
to participate in something bad would
happen to them for example refusing to
participate in the first challenge all
of your hair falls out refusing to
participate in the second challenge your
legs stop working
refusing to participate in the third
challenge
death it also makes sense that no one
would inform harry of the specifics of
these consequences including his
professors as the subject is quite
morbid and harry was just a young boy
what do you guys think would refusing to
participate result in death or something
else altogether comment down below also
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel to support future content
until next time harry did you put your
name into the goblet of fire dumbledore
asked calmly
[Music]